Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich.
Ja, liebe Chatkis, heute müssen wir mal etwas Kleines ausprobieren.
Deswegen ein spontaner Stream am Mittwoch.
Ich erzähle euch auch gleich, warum.
Ein bisschen anderes Gedudel anmachen.
Exzellent.
Und ich muss die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Hier ist immer noch brutalst warm.
28 Grad oder so.
Obwohl es gestern und heute
schon deutlich kühler gewesen ist.
Ja, Lautstärke passt.
Excellent, excellent.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal was trinken.
Ich bin irgendwie noch ziemlich kaputt.
Ich bin ja eben erst von der Arbeit gekommen.
Eigentlich wäre noch 33 Minuten
locker Joggen dran gewesen.
Fast schon Recovery-Runde.
Habe ich mir gedacht, spare ich mir heute.
Was sagst du zu dem
Proxmox und
Proxmox Backup?
Ist das, gell?
Proxmox Backup-Server-Problem, wenn du nichts mitgeguckt hast.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nichts mitbekommen. Zeig mal her.
Moment, gucken wir mal.
Interesting.
Das da?
Ne.
Hier, da?
Ach, was soll ich suchen?
Ah, Moment.
Das kenne ich.
Nicht bohren.
Bohren.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist ein Blog, da bin ich auch schon öfters mal drauf gelandet, bei irgendwelchen News.
Meinst du?
Ich hätte gerne, habe ich hier keinen Darkreader?
VNKS, warum habe ich keinen Darkreader?
Ich habe keinen Darkreader.
Okay, Chat, wir müssen erstmal den Linux-Mini-PC anmachen.
Sonst, ohne Darkreader bin ich zu geblendet.
Ist zu anstrengend.
Oder erzähle ich euch, was es mit RDP anstatt SSH auf sich hat.
Pace League, MonkaS, Allah.
Dass ich dann irgendwelche Leute im Zug habe
Die mich dann erkennen und mich nerven
Ne ne ne ne
Ihr wisst wie wenig Bock ich auf andere Leute
IRL habe
Logitech Software noch starten?
Ey, ich habe auf gar keinen Bock.
Seid mal froh, ich tue wenigstens nicht so dumm wie andere Influencers.
Sondern sagt gleich, was Sache ist.
Nicht wie die ganzen Beauty-Leute oder was auch immer es da gibt.
Oh Leute, ihr seid mir alle so furchtbar wichtig.
Und ich freue mich so, dass ihr alle da seid.
Wobei, dass ihr da seid, freue ich mich tatsächlich.
Aber nicht IRL.
Dass ihr hier im Chat seid, ja.
Was rebooten soll ich?
Sehr gute Idee.
Wir rebooten.
Ja, wir machen erstmal Reboot.
Ja, stell dich mal vor.
Irgendjemand will davon, dass ich Reboot sage.
Also.
Äh, Cornborn?
Nein.
Born?
City?
Born.
Wie vor ihr?
Block.
Ne, wie heißt das komische Block?
Born City, Alter.
Ja, das da.
Okay.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Schwerer Fehler in Virtualisierungslösung
und Proxmox führt zu Datenverlust.
Leute,
wie gut, dass ich so eine Kack-Netzwerkkarte
habe in meinem NAS.
Und deswegen das neue NAS mit Proxmox
noch nicht im Einsatz habe, oder?
Am besten immer
erstmal mit neuen Sachen
fünf Jahre auf die nächste LTS-Version
warten und dann ist es okay.
Dann ist es stable.
Dann ist es zwar
Outdated as fuck.
Und nervt rum.
Aber so komische Dinge hast du nicht.
Deswegen sind wir ja auch hier auf einem
Langzeit-LTS-Linux
unterwegs.
Habe ich jetzt
rebooted?
Ich habe nicht rebooted.
Ach komm, das müssen wir halt
updaten. Kein
Reboot jetzt. Also was
ist denn? In der Virtualisierungslösung
Proxmox gibt es einen schweren Bug,
der zu Datenverlust für
meine Backups nicht mal problemlos zurückgelesen
werden können. Aha.
Wir haben Rolling LTS, Leute,
haben wir hier laufen. Rolling LTS.
Es kommt zu Hängern
und andere virtuelle Maschinen können
unter Proxmox VE
8 oder 9 in bestimmten Fällen
sogar beschädigt werden.
Aha.
Und warum?
Ah, die wählen noch bald hier, ne?
Ist nicht bald in...
Osters in Sachsen?
Ja, am Wochenende, oder?
In Sachsen-Anhalt.
So, Wahlstelz am Start.
War das nicht am Wochenende?
Ich glaub schon.
Ein Blogleser hat mich zum
13. August
ein massives Problem
mit Proxmox
Backup Server und Zusammenspiel
ZFS Restore
Was zu irreparablen Datenverlust
derzeit noch, warum es zu Datenverlust kommt
Oh ja, gut
Da gibt's
Beim Versuch ein größeres
vm backup 3 bis 4 terabyte schon ordentliche vm steige die auslastung des servers massiv an
ok
ja und hat sich das box team ist dran ja gut da sind wir dran ist ja die standard antwort
von allen leuten in der it gibt zwei sachen ich nehme das mit und da sind wir dran
Wie oft ich das schon gesagt habe, Leute.
Aber das sagt schon ziemlich.
Guck mal mal, was da offiziell in diesem Post drin steht.
Ich hätte gedacht, der Thread ist länger.
Also wenn die sowas ins Backlog schieben
Jetzt haben wir 6-7 Zuschauer, Leute
Weiß, das ist schon wieder out
Und ich find's auch richtig dumm
Aber ist mir grad nur so aufgefallen
als ich auf den zweiten Bildschirm geschielt habe.
Ja, das sollte allerdings nicht in das Backlog kommen.
Das scheint mir relativ wichtig zu sein.
Guck mal, ein ähnliches Issue wurde auch an den Enterprise Support reported
und wird jetzt gerade investigated by our support engineers.
Also quasi Techniker ist informiert, sozusagen.
techniker ist informiert ja
gut ich bin davon nicht betroffen
bin davon einfach aus dem kunden nicht betroffen weil ich brauchst noch so nicht im einsatz habe
seht ihr mal leute alles ist für was gut diese dreckige schlechte real tech
netzwerkkarte die mich schon seit monaten abfuckt ist ja daran schuld dass
ich mein nass noch nicht in betrieb habe und mein nass sollte ja zumindest so wie
geplant als als host system proxmox drauf haben
und also nass streckstrich server für gebastelt und das hätte ich jetzt schon
im einsatz gehabt auf der anderen seite scheint das problem ja nur zu bestehen
wenn man restore laufen lässt du hast nichts verpasst wir haben uns hier nur
gerade was durchgelesen dass es bei proxmox backup restore probleme gibt
also
Ja.
Aber nachdem bei mir ja eh nichts kaputt geht,
per Definition, ihr wisst ja,
funktioniert immer alles perfekt, first try.
Wie man auch immer im Stream sieht.
Wann haben wir im Stream schon mal was
mehrfach machen müssen?
Hab ich das Problem nicht, weil ich muss ja keine Backups
restoren, weil ich hab keine Ausfälle.
dementsprechend habe ich auf der Arbeit natürlich auch nur Services, die ich betreue, 100% Uptime.
Soll ich aber was sagen?
Meine Services auf der Arbeit haben wirklich 100% Uptime, die ich betreue.
Das liegt aber daran, dass sie nicht wirklich 100% Uptime haben,
sondern die haben 100% Uptime in dem definierten Zeitfenster, wo sie zur Verfügung stehen müssen.
Also wenn ich da am Wochenende irgendwas patchen muss oder wenn da Wartungsarbeiten am Wochenende sind,
dann ist das nicht in den garantierten verfügbaren Zeiten drin.
Und dann zählt das natürlich auch nicht als Downtime.
Deswegen haben alle meine Services, um die ich mich kümmere, auf der Arbeit am 100%.
Obwohl sie nicht wirklich 100% haben.
Darf man das dann überhaupt als 100% zählen, Chat?
Wie seht ihr das?
ein Service, der zu 100% da ist,
in den Zeiten, wo definiert ist,
dass er zur Verfügung stehen soll,
versus ein Service, der halt
das erfüllt,
aber nicht wirklich 100%ig zur Verfügung steht.
Was würdet ihr sagen?
Ist das 100% Uptime?
Oder zählt
wirklich 24-7 Uptime?
Egal,
wann Betriebszeiten sind.
Also wenn man nämlich sagt, es ist egal,
wann Betriebszeiten sind, dann haben meine Services
natürlich nicht 100% Uptime.
Aber nahezu.
Genau. Ja.
Im Prinzip ist es so.
Ich würde dann aber auf jeden Fall
eher die 100% nehmen.
Weil die 100% klingt
immer besser.
Und man muss weniger zu erklären.
Doch, also bei uns zählt das allerdings nur, wenn das davor und danach in die normalen
Betriebszeiten reinfällt.
Und das ist ja am Wochenende meistens nicht.
Würde es gehen, dass du einen Ausweichserver hast, während du den Produktivserver umbruchst?
Ja, ja, das geht.
Das ist eine Frage der Architektur, wie man das aufbaut und teilweise auch der Anwendung.
Wie man das macht. Aber das geht in der Regel schon.
Das geht in der Regel schon. Aber ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin da viel zu faul für.
Wenn wir nämlich ein Service haben, wo definiert ist, Montag bis Freitag, ich denke mir jetzt einfach mal irgendwas aus, von 8 bis 18 Uhr soll er verfügbar sein.
Und ich mache am Samstag scheduled Betriebssystem-Updates mit Reboot.
Das schedule ich doch nicht servern nacheinander
Da wird einfach gescheduled
Bam, komplette Umgebung, zack
Die ist dann halt immer eine Viertelstunde down
Aber am Samstag juckt es ja keinen
Oder am Sonntag
Da mache ich mir gar nicht die Mühe
Wenn das komplett außerhalb der normalen Betriebszeit liegt
Warum auch
So Leute
Jetzt erzähle ich euch mal was
Also.
Wir bekommen auf der Arbeit neue VMs.
Oder, was heißt wir bekommen?
Wir können, wir können.
Wir können auf der Arbeit neue VMs beantragen.
Warum auch immer ich jetzt NeoFetch aufgemacht habe, macht absolut keinen Sinn.
Die Kiste, auf der ich bin, hat null mit der VM zu tun, nicht auf der Arbeit.
Also, ignoriert einfach, dass ich hier unten NeoFetch eingeblendet habe.
Also.
Wir bekommen auf der Arbeit neue VMs.
Ist VMware jetzt doch zu teuer?
Ne, ne, ne, ist immer noch VMware.
Ist immer noch VMware.
Natürlich immer noch Business Enterprise.
Ja, oh Mut, das sieht gut aus.
So sieht mein
Verfügbarkeitsreport auch aus,
bei den ganzen Services.
Aber wir haben
ein anderes Tool, das sieht nicht so schön aus,
wie eures im Report.
Und das sieht hässlich aus,
wie eine Webseite von 1995.
Naja, okay. Also, es ist immer noch VMWare.
Aber wir haben die Möglichkeit, ein neuer VM zu bekommen mit, jetzt haltet euch fest, Grafikkarte drin.
Ich vermute mal, unter der Haube wird das mit...
Wie heißt dieses Nvidia-Ding, was du clustern kannst, auf VMWare?
Ähm
Also SAIOV
Ist das bei Netzwerkkarten und sonstigen Sachen
Heißt das da auch SAIOV
NVLink, ne
Ja das meine ich
Also es gibt wohl Grafikkarten
Von Nvidia
Die kann man sozusagen
Partitionieren und dann direkt an
VMs passt thun
Das heißt, du hast dann eine Grafikkarte, die unterstützt, keine Ahnung, 16 virtuelle Grafikkarten.
Und dann kannst du damit 16 VMs quasi ausstatten.
So, und wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit für die Leute, die High-Performance-VMs brauchen.
Was mir natürlich selbstverständlich sind.
Was sonst?
Was die kosten, die sind bestimmt schweineteuer.
Und in der heutigen Zeit wahrscheinlich nochmal doppelt so teuer.
Zumindest kann man jetzt High-Performance-VMs...
Ich hab kein... Ich weiß...
Okay, wir... Warte mal. Wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal. Ähm...
Welche...
Warte mal.
Welche GPUs von Nvidia
können SRIOV
und gesplittet werden
in VMware?
Wollen wir erst mal gucken, wie dieser Campel überhaupt heißt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Was ist...
Chat, was ist...
Okay.
L20480.
Okay, was...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was kostet sowas?
Schnapper.
Also im Prinzip das, was du für eine 5090 bezahlst.
Nur mit ein bisschen mehr Speicher, gell?
bisschen mehr speicher aber ich weiß halt nicht wie wie leistungsstark so ein
ding ist also also series leute ich habe absolut keine ahnung ob das das ist was
wir haben null plan absolut kein plan also ich guck mal was was kostet denn
sowas hier zum beispiel ja das kostet alles so in dem dreh
Okay, guck mal mal, was Highend kostet.
96 Gig DDR7 Speicher.
Leute.
Da reden wir aber mal von ganz anderen Hausnummern hier.
Exzellente Preise, würde ich sagen.
15K bis 20K.
Ey, man, so viel hat früher so ein voll ausgebautes HS23-Plate gekostet.
Also das ist schon, würde sagen, recht ordentlich, ja.
Was soll ich gucken?
Blackwell
B300
Was ist das für eine
KI-Infrastruktur-Lösung
Okay
Kostet
Gibt es nicht mal zu kaufen
Bye
Ah, das ist ein kompletter
GPU-Server.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Da wird wahrscheinlich kein Vmware drauflaufen.
Hahaha.
Ein Schnapper.
Halbe Million. Easy.
Also Leute, wenn man
ein KI-Cluster aufbauen will,
ist das nicht verkehrt.
Das würde ich sagen, geht ins Geld hier.
Also, Chat,
nicht mal, wenn ihr alle
und wir gehen jetzt nicht von denen aus, die da sind,
sondern wirklich mal sagen,
selbst wenn alle Leute,
die am Sonntag, übrigens den Stream
vom Sonntag habe ich gelöscht, weil ich meine IP
geleakt habe, nicht wundern.
Den Stream, den
aufwachen Stream vom Sonntag.
Ich habe mal wieder nicht aufgepasst beim
rumklicken im Browser.
Ähm...
Also ich hab sonntags irgendwie so keine Ahnung.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal...
Lass uns mal gucken, wo bloß...
Also selbst wenn alle Leute,
die sonntags
den Stream geguckt
haben...
Also 2000...
Dann erkennt sich so genau. 2500
Leute, selbst wenn die
ein Tier...
T3-Sub. Ich weiß gar nicht, was kosten
T3-Sub?
Was kosten das eigentlich?
24.
Null, Alter.
Ja, Bezos muss neue Raketen
bauen.
Okay, selbst
wenn jeder, der nur mal
kurz den Stream angeklickt hat am Sonntag,
ein T3-Sub
abschließt,
haben wir nur einen Bruch
vor dem KI-Server zusammen, ja?
Und das zweite Problem bei so einer Kiste wäre, glaube ich, dass das auch nicht ganz wenig Strom verbraucht, würde ich mal drauf tippen.
Wahrscheinlich verbrauchst du da in einem halben Jahr nochmal so viel Strom.
Oh, da wird auch noch schneller.
Nochmal so viel Strom.
Stimmt, ich bekomme ja sogar nur die Hälfte.
Selbst wenn ich alles bekommen würde, würde es immer noch nicht ansatzweise ausreichen.
Ähm.
Ja, und selbst der Strom kostet wahrscheinlich nochmal das Gleiche nach einer Weile.
Also das ist echt krass.
Gut, nee, also das haben wir da garantiert nicht.
Zumindest, um jetzt mal zurück auf das zu kommen.
Also, wir können uns jetzt auf der Arbeit neue VMs bestellen mit Grafikkarte drin.
Ich vermute mal, dass das auf irgendwie hier sowas basiert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel RAM die Grafikkarte, die man dann durchgereicht hat, bekommt oder sowas.
Kein Schimmer.
Aber, aber, es sollte zumindest für den modernen Linux Desktop auf Wayland Basis reichen.
Und es muss auf Wayland-Basis sein, jetzt kommt ja der Hit, es muss auf Wayland-Basis sein, weil als Betriebssystem ist, wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das bescheuertste Betriebssystem für so einen Anwendungsfall gesetzt, nämlich Red Hat 10.
Red Hat 10 mit quasi GPU-Paththrough und irgendeinem uralten Desktop auf Wayland-Basis.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt habe ich mal nachgeguckt heute, mal kurz, wie das so ausschaut.
Es ist anscheinend so, dass man unter Red Hat kein RDP-Server mehr installieren kann.
Beziehungsweise kein VNC-Server mehr installieren kann.
Wobei, wir brauchen eh RDP in dem Fall.
Man kann keinen RDP-Server mehr installieren, weil Red Hat 10 bringt nur noch Wayland-Gedöns mit.
Und das Einzige, wie man RDP mit Wayland machen kann, ist, Gnome zu installieren und das RDP-Backend von Gnome zu verwenden.
Ich kann nicht Sunshine versuchen.
Ich kann ja den Client nicht frei installieren.
Ich kann ja auf der Kiste, von der ich auf die VM zugreife, nichts zusätzlich installieren.
Leider
Also es wird
Es wird auf RDP rauslaufen
Ja
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus
Ich mach mal den Streamtitel
Bisschen anders
Auch kein Flatpack
Ne ne ne
Der Client ist Windows
Ich muss irgendwie
von meinem Windows Notebook
da dran kommen.
Ich habe ein Windows Notebook.
Aktuell mache ich das so.
Ich verbinde mich per SSH
drauf und hole mir einen
Terminal über X-Forwarding rüber.
Das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen laggy,
weil X-Forwarding ist jetzt nun, naja,
nicht so das geilste, was es gibt.
So, und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, ich muss das mal ausprobieren.
Ich installiere mir jetzt,
also wir können das ja mal zusammen ausprobieren.
Ich installiere mir jetzt hier einfach mal einen
Docker-Container mit
Rocky Linux 10 oder sowas.
Und
dann gucken wir mal, wie wir uns da
per ADP drauf verbinden können.
Also im Endeffekt machen wir
sowas hier.
Docker run.
Ne, sowas machen wir nicht.
Alter,
was habe ich da so viel gedöhnt?
Wir machen auch nicht CentOS 7.
machen wir vielleicht auch mal ein R drauf.
Da ist drauf. So, wir machen jetzt einfach
was nehmen wir denn? Rocky Linux 10
nehmen wir jetzt
und wir Port 418839
zu 8,8, nee
zu 3389. 3389
ist RDP Port, gell? Oder
Chat, bin ich, bin ich, bin ich, oder bin ich ganz
verwirrt jetzt?
Port
RDP, ja. Ich meine,
man kann das auch irgendwo anders drauf starten.
So, da starten wir jetzt mal.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Achso, was ist denn?
Ist es Rocky Linux?
Docker Rocky Linux.
Was haben die denn für einen...
Ah ja, Rocky Linux heißt.
Äh, Moment. Warum...
Äh, Chat, warum gibt's da...
Hä?
Warum gibt es kein Rocky Linux 10 Docker Container?
Dann nehmen wir Alma Linux, ist auch okay
Bin ich jetzt blöd, warum gibt es das nicht
Das da vielleicht
Okay, das gibt es
Wäre Fedora nicht besser
Nein, es ist ja ein Red Hat, was wir auf der Arbeit haben
Es muss ein Red Hat sein
Also ich will das wirklich mit dem, was Red Hat 10
Am Start hat, ausprobieren
Da geht es ja jetzt schon nochmal los
Ich, wir müssen jetzt
Wir müssen da jetzt googlen
Ich hab wirklich, ich hab absolut keinen Plan
Wie man das überhaupt, was?
Moment
Moment, Moment, Moment
Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat
Ich dachte Clear war Shell Build-In
Ist das nicht so?
Rocky Linux ist Red Hat
Das ist ein Red Hat Nachbau
Genauso wie Almalings
Es gibt
Es gibt was, wo kein Clear installiert ist
Wie installiert man das nach?
Gibt's das ernsthaft?
Okay, okay
Jan, what provides
Clear
Es kommt mir bitte keiner mit DNF um die Ecke
Jan, beste
Endcurses
Äh, ja, das sind fast
Übrigens, by the way, Chat
Ich weiß nicht, ob es euch mal aufgefallen ist
Also
Red Hat 10 ist der Package Manager
Viel schneller geworden im Vergleich zu den älteren
Linux-Systemen, guck mal, das kommt jetzt
Das kommt jetzt fast an das neue Upt dran
An Pac-Man kommt es noch nicht ran, aber es ist
Deutlich schneller geworden
So
Upt, äh, ja
install wir machen noch bäsch completion yes okay aber neue bäsch dass wir den ganzen krempel haben
okay wie macht man das jetzt was ist deiner meinung nach der beste package manager ich
bin art schienungs fern also von der von der paket auswahl wobei man das bei art schienungs
jetzt fairer halber nicht eigentlich nicht sagen kann weil art schienungs hat ja auch nicht alle
Pakete in den offiziellen Quellen drin.
Sag mal, zumindest vom Handling her
und der Geschwindigkeit her
finde ich Pac-Man mit Abstand am angenehmsten.
Was ich halt auch ganz cool an Arch Linux an sich finde,
ist, dass du das Arch User Repo hast.
Es gibt aber glücklicherweise
unter Linux ja mittlerweile mehr Möglichkeiten,
Sachen zu installieren.
Es muss ja nicht Snap sein, es kann
Flatpak sein, es können App Images sein.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch viele Native Binaries,
die man einfach ausführen kann.
Aber das Arch-User-Repo ist schon nicht verkehrt
Auch wenn es
Problematisch ist
Zur Zeit, was Supply Chain Angriffe angeht
Das ist richtig
Aber Pac-Man ist mir am liebsten
Ansonsten mag ich Abt
Auch, ich musste mal vor Jahren
Ich weiß noch, das ist eine ganze Weile her
Musste ich mal einen
Zappix Agent, glaube ich war
Das ist eine neuere Version vom Zappix Agent
Als sie bereitgestellt haben
Musste ich mal als Debian Package packen
Also das Debian Package Format mit ihren Post Hooks und was weiß ich, ist echt wirr, aber ich mag abt vom Feeling her.
Der Package Manager, der mir am wenigsten gefällt, ist tatsächlich YAM bzw. DNF RPM passierte Pakete.
Weiß nicht, auch wenn es der ist, den ich wahrscheinlich am öftesten benutze, weil Business Enterprise Umfeld halt irgendwie Red Hat mag,
würde ich trotzdem sagen,
mir gefällt das am wenigsten.
Ich meine, es gibt ja
nicht so viele im Endeffekt,
die verbreitet sind.
Was ist im Endeffekt
verbreitet?
Es ist Debian, Ubuntu,
das ist Abt,
dann hast du
Redhead und Suse,
Fedora und
Alma und Rocky,
Das ist Yam oder bei Suse.
Bei Suse ist es Zipper.
Oder ist es...
Chat, irgendjemand mal in letzter Zeit Suse verwendet.
Ist es da immer noch Zipper, was man verwendet als Package-Installer?
Früher gab es noch YAS zum Konfigurieren.
Aber ich glaube Zipper ist es bei Suse.
Für RPM-Packages.
Dann hast du Alpine.
APK.
Dann hast du noch so ganz olles Zeug.
So wie Slackware.
die mit ihren komischen Binary-Packages rumhantieren im Target-Set-Format oder sowas.
Ganz, ganz wirres Zeug.
Und ansonsten hast du noch so ein paar Nischen-Dinger, ja, die beispielsweise OpenWrt und sowas.
Wobei OpenWrt, hat OpenWrt nicht auch mittlerweile APK?
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher jetzt, ehrlich gesagt.
da gibt es ein paar Nischen-Dinger.
Aber von den großen Distributionen,
Leute, im Endeffekt war es das,
ne?
Was da großartig verbreitet ist.
Wir reden jetzt nicht
vom Desktop.
Nicht vom Desktop. Desktop kannst du noch
Archilux in allen möglichen Varianten.
Es gibt ja noch
ein paar mehr Nischen-Sachen. Es gibt ja noch
Void-Linux
zum Beispiel, die haben irgendwas ganz eigenes,
glaube ich.
Und da ist noch Kali.
Wobei, Kali ist Debian-basiert, oder?
Fragezeichen? Bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Solche Dinger.
Aber wenn du mal so von Serverbetriebssystemen ausgehst,
das ist im Endeffekt,
ist das Debian oder Ubuntu
oder bis das Enterprise-Finanzbranche-Umfeld
Red Hat.
Und Leute, die keinen Bock auf die Lizenzgebühren von Red Hat haben,
dann ist es dann vielleicht einmal Linux oder Rocky Linux.
Vielleicht auch irgendwie
noch ein Suse, wenn sie da drauf stehen.
Aber das war es dann auch. Mehr ist es da eigentlich nicht. Auch BSD ist es da. Ganz ehrlich, ich habe BSD noch nie im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld gesehen.
Der einzige Fall, wo ich mal indirekt einen BSD gesehen habe, ist beim alten Arbeitgeber das Portal, wo man drauf gekommen ist, wenn man sich per WLAN verbunden hat. Das lief auf OpenSense oder PFSense Basis und das ist ja ein OpenBSD, glaube ich.
ne? PFSense,
PFSense OpenBSD oder FreeBSD,
keine Ahnung. Das ist ein BSD.
Und das ist einfach das einzige BSD, was ich hier
mal so wirklich irgendwo so
in the wild gesehen hab.
Sonst noch nie BSD.
An euch, Chat, habt ihr
bei euch auf der Arbeit oder habt ihr
bei euch im professionellen Umfeld schon
mal BSD live gesehen?
Und wenn ja, für irgendwas anderes als
PFSense und
und Konsorten.
Weil ansonsten,
keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht noch,
vielleicht noch die,
also Router-Switches mit BSD
habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite, Leute,
man könnte jetzt ja sagen, wir haben alle schon mal was mit
BSD benutzt.
Die Playstation basiert auf
OpenBSD, glaube ich.
Also, schon,
Ich glaube seit der PS2 basiert das auf OpenBSD.
Die Playstation hat kein Linux.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also du konntest auf der PS3 ein Linux installieren.
Aber das Sony eigene Betriebssystem ist auf BSD Basis.
Genauso wie wenn man sich macOS anguckt.
macOS ist ja ganz weit unten drunter auch irgendwo BSD.
Aber damit hast du nichts zu tun.
Das ist, das ist, äh,
irgendwelches proprietäres Zeug drumherum.
Das
sieht man jetzt im Rechenzentrum eher weniger.
Ansonsten hab ich so
in the wild noch nie einen BSD gesehen.
Ah,
So, jetzt wirst du noch mal googeln, wie das funktioniert.
Also jetzt habe ich Endcursors installiert.
Kann ich das auch clear machen?
Okay, nice.
Wichtigsten Sachen funzen schon mal.
Mal kurz gucken, mal kurz gucken, ob mein Netzwerkkrempel denn funktioniert.
Docker PS, wir leiten Port 3389.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier netcat-l3389 mache,
ab install netcat.
Was? Ach so, oh man.
Wie installiert man das?
Okay, nc, meinetwegen.
nc-
Ist das minus l minus p?
Kann man das nehmen?
Ach so, wir machen doch vorher nochmal einen tmux,
dass ich mich ja nicht immer neu drauf verbinden muss.
Yes.
da hatten wir hier oben auch, also
NetSat-L ist es,
kann man das immer nicht merken, das ist nämlich beim BSD
NetCat anders als beim
Knu NetCat oder was das andere ist.
So, listen
wir denn jetzt da drauf. Curl
Local Host
Mama, 3389. Bam.
Jawohl. ChatGIS.
Es funktioniert. Wir kommen da per Netzwerk hin.
Exzellent.
Also, wie funzt das jetzt?
Gugeln wir mal. Red Hat 10
rdp access
remotely accessing the desktop
it is built directly into the gnome desktop environment via gnome remote desktop
so wenn ich das suche finde ich dann was
au
Aber hier gibt es sogar einen Guide.
Oh ne, nixOS.
MonkeS, da ist die...
Da ist die Config verwirrender als alles andere.
Ein Guide.
Gibt es da irgendwie?
Headless.
Such mal mal Headless.
Headless Remote Desktop Setup Process.
Okay, wie fonst du hast?
Also wir installieren jetzt erst einmal
wir installieren jetzt erst einmal das hier.
Wir machen das jetzt mal einfach richtig
noob-style. Wir installieren das und hoffen
dann einfach, dass es funktioniert, okay? Easy.
Welcher Service muss dann?
Status Gnome
Remote Desktop. Okay.
Chat meint,
es funktioniert direkt. Ich habe ja meine Zweifel.
Das wäre nicht Wayland und
Gnome stellst, wenn es auf Anhieb
funktionieren würde.
Äh.
Oh, shit!
Nein, ich
brauch dafür System D!
Okay, Container
stellst, schau mal außen vor.
Fuck.
Leute, jetzt bräuchten wir den
4M Champ.
Jetzt bräuchten wir den 4M Champ.
Hatten wir nicht letztens?
Sekunde, Leute. Moment.
Hatten wir nicht letztens...
Was ist für dich die beste System-D-Alternative?
Für Container?
Für Container gibt es ja eigentlich nur Supervisor, die...
Ich...
Chat, wenn ihr mich fragt,
ETC in die D-Beste.
So wie 1998.
Wir hatten doch letztens was.
Das hieß doch irgendwie MSB? Genau.
MSB Run Debian.
Da können wir jetzt einfach sagen, MSB run Alma Linux 10.
Da haben wir jetzt nämlich eine echte VM.
Es ist bloß die Frage, wie wir da jetzt Ports weiterleiten.
Probieren wir das einfach mal wie bei Docker.
Okay.
MSB PS.
Hey, wisst ihr, das finde ich gut, wenn die sich an Docker Command Line orientieren.
Da weiß man immer wenigstens, was Sache ist.
So, jetzt müssen wir nur noch dafür sorgen, dass das Ding an jedem Port lauscht.
Jawohl.
Okay.
Äh, yum.
Install.
Encurses.
Tmux.
Htop.
Destat.
War alles mögliche, was wir gebrauchen können.
Git.
Ja, okay, das reicht erstmal.
Äh, und, und, und, und, abbrechen, abbrechen, abbrechen.
Und Netcat.
Das ist alles Pit Null. Das ist normal.
Was?
Unable to... Muss ich erstmal ein Update vorher machen, oder wie?
Es gibt kein Hardtop?
Was ist denn da los?
Wollen die mich...
Hardtop gibt es?
Was?
Wie, es gibt kein Hardtop mehr?
Das ist das wichtigste Package?
Das habe ich auf allen meinen Red Hat 10 Systemen auch installiert.
Warum gibt es das denn mehr?
Ja, ne,
Jam-Install war nochmal
Bash-Completion.
Comp-
lesion.
Yes.
Bash starten.
Hm.
Jam-Wort
provides H-Top.
Hä?
Chat, bin ich jetzt...
Bin ich jetzt komplett verwirrt?
Warum gibt es das nicht?
Ich habe das auf jeden meiner Kisten installiert, Hartop.
Kommt das vielleicht aus irgendeinem Spezial-Repo oder sowas?
Es gibt auch kein...
Ah, nee, das ist Jam-Repos, D.
Ah!
Es ist Epel.
Das ist bei uns quasi schon Standard-Milch eingerichtet.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, dann...
Das wird's erklären.
Nee, das ist bei uns schon starten.
Jetzt war ich echt verwirrt.
Ich hab gedacht, wie kann das sein?
Ich hab das auf allen unseren Kisten drauf.
Warum gibt es jetzt eigentlich ein Upgrade
Nachdem ich es eben gerade installiert habe
Okay
Install H-Top
Ja, install H-Top
Chat, wie würdet ihr das aussprechen?
H-Top oder wie die coolen Leute H-Top
Aber ich bin für H-Top
Top, könnte man auch sagen
Top
System, CTL.
Ist das jetzt überhaupt
Status?
Das ist nicht...
Leute, der VM-Champ.
Ich sag's euch, der VM-Champ war doch
der beste.
Der VM-Champ war's.
Leider ist der VM-Champ kaputt.
Jetzt muss ich mir
ernsthaft ein Rocky-Linux-Image runterladen
und in der VM installieren, weil der ganze Shit
nicht funktioniert.
Kann man denn?
Kann man denn mit System D?
Kann man...
QEMU einfach eine Q-Ka...
Ja, kann ich machen.
Ähm...
Vielleicht haben die hier...
Ach, man kann ja... Ey, wisst ihr, wie...
Wisst ihr, wie mich das abfuckt, dass man GitHub
nur noch verwenden kann, wenn man eingeloggt ist?
Gescheit.
Jetzt will ich hier drin nach System D suchen.
geht nicht.
So dumm, Alter. Das ist so dumm.
Wenn man Glück hat,
können wir hier jetzt vielleicht suchen?
Okay, das scheint zu gehen.
Kann das irgendwie starten
mit System D?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr was? Wir machen die Oldschool-Variante.
Wir machen die Oldschool-Variante.
Du hast doch deinen Netboot-Server.
Das ist richtig.
Die große Preisfrage ist nur...
Hab ich da...
Hab ich da ein Red Hat drinnen?
Das probieren wir jetzt mal, Leute.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Wir machen jetzt den Klassiker.
Wirt Manager.
Bam.
Yes.
Ich muss bestimmt noch LibWirt und so installieren.
Oder ist das LibWirt?
wird oder ist schon installiert das ist schon in zx wird manager bm aber es juckt mich das
okay ich glaube ich glaube wird die lip wird es nicht gestartet system ctl status wird die
disabled start wie war das enable minus minus now wird manager warum ist da jetzt kein connection
Cuemo
Ha, da sind wir
Wir können
VMs starten, excellent
Dann starten wir hier mal eine VM
In der Hoffnung, dass mein PXE-Server
Noch an ist
Und auch ein Red Hat Image
Irgendwie surft
Mit 8 G... Ah ja, ist doch kein Problem
8 G Gramm
Oder 7 G Gramm, 7 G Swap
Das passt schon.
Das passt schon, Chet.
Easy.
Also, new.
No hyperweise options were found.
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich
QEMU nicht installiert habe?
KVM? QEMU?
Was muss man dafür installieren?
Und ArchWiki.
ArchWiki.
KVM.
Hardware Support checken.
Okay, das haben wir auf jeden Fall.
Okay, das ist die schönere Ausgabe davon.
Excellent.
So, Kernel Support, das haben wir bestimmt alles aktualisiert.
Das passt schon.
Mod, Probe, Nested, Virtualisierung, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Das brauchen wir auch alles nicht.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, was ich mir...
Hier.
Cuemo System.
Und was muss ich mir denn überhaupt installieren dafür?
Welche Packages brauche ich denn dafür?
Arch, QEMU, KVM,
which packages to install?
Wirt Manager haben wir schon gemacht.
LibWirt haben wir auch schon gemacht.
QEMU Desktop?
Was zum Teufel ist QEMU Desktop?
Das ist doch Cheap Aid, oder?
Equimo Setup
for Desktop Environments.
Okay.
Wenn die das sagen.
Okay, jetzt.
Darf ich jetzt?
Oh, oh, ah.
Okay, Network Install.
Weiter. Ach so,
Oh, ne, okay, okay. Manual installen.
Choose operating system.
Red Hat.
Red Hat 10.
Eigentlich egal. Memory.
Ja, gut.
Was ist denn das kleinste?
Okay, 1024.
Okay, komm. Ne, hier.
3000. Das gönnen wir ihm.
3072, okay.
Und CPUs kriegt er aber 4.
Meinst du, komm, 4096.
Ich hab halt nicht viel RAM.
oder aber ich schraube jetzt mein NAS auf und baue das RAM in den Mini-PC ein.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, auch nicht so schlau.
Okay, 4 GB.
Create Disk Image.
Enable Storage.
Ja, ja, Storage ist gut.
80 GB.
Next.
Customize.
Bridge.
Okay, was ist ein VDPA-Device?
Wird I.O. Data Path Acceleration?
Absolut kein blassen Schimmer.
Mac VTAP Device.
Does not work for host to guest network communication.
Okay, Bridge Device.
Haben wir denn...
Bridge...
Hotels...
Wie heißt der Kram?
Bridge.
Bridge Hotels gibt es nicht mehr?
Oder?
Bridge Hotels gibt es nur noch als Our Package?
What the fuck?
Okay, aber Bridge Hotels ist ja auch
Outdated, Overrated, Cheapated.
Man kann die Dinge auch hier drüber irgendwie managen.
References?
Das ging doch.
Man konnte doch auch hier drüber Netzwerkgedöns managen.
Irgendwie.
Virtual Networks.
Ja.
Wir brühe null.
Aber wir brühe null ist nut.
Das wollen wir ja nicht.
Ach nee, das funzt jetzt ja wieder nicht.
Alter, ist das abfuck.
Aber das macht nichts.
Wir können sagen, Mac VTab?
Das finde ich halt immer noch richtig eklig unter Linux hier mit Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Weil wir müssen ja gar nicht davon drauf zugreifen können.
Aber wir wollen per SSH da drauf zugreifen.
Boah, ist das eklig.
Wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf.
Ich mach nen...
Wir machen das nicht damit.
Ich mach hier einfach vor allem erstellen, so ein gutes...
Doch.
Doch, doch, kann ich. Das Problem ist, wenn du das machst, dann kommst du von deiner Linux-Hostkiste nicht auf die VM.
Was ziemlich reudig ist.
Weil ich weiß nicht, ob es da mittlerweile bessere Varianten gibt, ehrlich gesagt.
Gibt es da mittlerweile irgendwas Besseres? Ich glaube nicht.
Weil ansonsten müsste ich ein Bridge-Device anlegen und mein Netzwerk-Dings in das Bridge-Device packen und so.
Das ist ziemlich dumm.
Wir machen das jetzt anders. Wir starten jetzt einfach hier
vor MWR.
Wir machen die
vor M einfach hier rein. Wir brauchen es ja nur zum
installieren. Pog Desktop
PXE Boot. PXE Boot klingt ganz
gut. Aber wir machen mal
PXE Boot zur Sicherheit
mit UEFI. Okay, ist auch UEFI.
Da haben wir nämlich 16 GB RAM,
32 GB Harddrive,
Griff,
Griff die Leine. Danke schön für den Sub.
Das müsste eigentlich besser passen.
escape hämmern.
Wir wollen
ein EFI-Network-Boot machen.
Und jetzt wollen wir hoffen, dass mein Raspberry Pi für PXE-Boot
noch funktioniert.
Es scheint so.
Bei VM geht kein Wayland.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Wir machen ja Wayland in der VM
und starten das nicht.
Das ist egal.
Wir starten das ja nicht.
Wir wollen das ja nur für RDP haben.
Ich hoffe, das geht.
So, wir wollen jetzt Netboot XYZ haben.
Weil hier drin habe ich kein Red Hat.
Oder kein Alma Linux.
Mal gucken, was es da gibt.
Okay, wo könnte das jetzt drin sein?
Linux Network installen.
Alpine Arch.
Alma Linux, da ist es doch.
Alma Linux 10 Latest.
Wisst ihr, wie lang es her ist,
dass ich in Red Hat mal installiert habe von Hand?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das ausschaut.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Also das letzte Mal, als ich Red Hat installiert habe von Hand,
das war noch mit CDs, mit 8 CDs oder so,
ins Rechenzentrum.
laufen. Das war das letzte Mal, dass ich
Red Hat mit dem Installer installiert habe.
So lange ist das schon her.
Weiß gar nicht, wie der Installer
überhaupt ausschaut.
Das ist glaube ich relativ
default Gnome, oder?
Ich installiere keine grafische Oberfläche.
Ich will ja, dass das wie ein Headless-Server ist.
Dann mal zu gucken.
Ah, schauen wir mal.
Siehste mal, muss man wieder einen riesen Akt machen
Kann das sein, dass das nicht richtig runterlädt?
Muss man wieder einen riesen Akt machen, damit man es überhaupt testen kann
Äh
Macht das? Ja
Okay
use graphical mode via
oh alter
man kann
wait a minute
man kann use graphical mode
bei remote desktop protokoll
machen das hab ich ja noch nie ausprobiert
please
provide rdp username und password
ok max
massive geheimes password
kommt keiner drauf
bug
Geht gut los
Wie wärs mir jetzt mit IP-Anzeigen?
So IP-Anzeigen, Redhead, oder?
Oh, da steht ja sogar oben die IP
Ich hab nix gesagt, Leute
2, 1, 1, 9
Also
Machen wir das mal unter Linux
Was ist ein guter RDP-Client unter Linux eigentlich?
Ich hab schon seit 15 Jahren keinen mehr
Verwendet
Free-RDP kenne ich von früher noch
Ich brauche keinen Gui, ne?
Ohne Gui
Ohne Gui, immer noch Free-RDP
Free-RDP
Hä?
Wie war das nochmal?
Das ist so ein Ding.
Die machst du.
X3-ADP.
Genau.
1, 1, 9 oder 1, 1, 6?
1, 1, 6?
Was?
Unzupadded Command Line
Syntax.
okay das ist das ist hrq das geht nicht so einfach dass man eine ip hinten
angibt
was
minus v warum denn das
das war eine knackte sonntags minus v doppelpunkt
Yes.
Achso.
Ich dab.
Domain, Passwort.
Wir haben einen Installer.
Wobbly Installer, Leute.
Wobble, wobble.
Willkommen.
Nein, nein. Wir installieren das ganz bestimmt nicht in Deutsch.
Wir installieren das in
Kona Englisch.
So, was wollen wir denn noch?
Keyboard Layout.
Nee, Keyboard Layout hätte ich tatsächlich gerne German.
No Dead Keys und kein Englisch.
Geh weg.
Äh, dann.
Server with GUI.
Nein, Server.
Dann.
Wollte ich sonst noch irgendwas machen?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube, das war es.
Achso.
Root-Account ist disabled.
No users will be created.
Okay, Root-Account disabled ist in Ordnung.
Max.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Massive geheimes Passwort.
Gut, ich bin root danach.
Darf ich sudo?
Ah.
Partitionierung.
Automatic.
Die Installationsführung ist ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, ich weiß, da war mal Debian drauf, aber wen juckt's?
Okay.
Wo wir gehen?
Bam!
Das ist echt Premiere.
Ich habe den Red Hat Installer...
Ich vermute mal,
hat irgendjemand von euch den grafischen Red Hat Installer
innerhalb der letzten 15 Jahre mal verwendet?
Ist das das gleiche wie der hier,
nur dass die das Logo ausgetauscht haben?
Oder haben die das schon customised hier bei Alma Linux?
Weil letztendlich ist ja Alma Linux
quasi der Nachfolger von CentOS,
so ein bisschen, so mit Rocky Linux zusammen,
die quasi die Software von Red Hat nehmen
und alle Red Hat
Copyright Sachen
austauschen.
Also ich würde mal vermuten, die Installation sieht bei Red Hat
genauso aus mittlerweile.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe die letzten 15 Jahre kein Red Hat mehr von Hand installiert.
Also keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Guck mal hier. Passt.
Passt SE Linux.
Das geht einfach immer.
Aber mir macht das schon mal Hoffnung, dass das, was ich vorhabe, einfach funktioniert.
Weil wenn der Installer per RDP funktioniert...
Und ich habe da, glaube ich, auch irgendwas von Wayland vorher gelesen hier.
Äh, Moment.
Guck mal hier, start in Chrome Desktop RDP.
Start in Chrome Remote Desktop in RDP Mode.
Dann habe ich die Vermutung, dass das auch mit dem, was ich vorhabe, relativ easy funktionieren wird.
Und dann müssen wir als nächstes gucken, wie man nur eine blöde Frage haben, wie geht das mit RDP und Headless.
Der startet dann GUI-Sachen über RDP und nicht halt direkt auf dem Monitor.
Du kannst dich ja auch bei Windows einloggen, ohne dass du am Computer selbst eingeloggt bist über RDP.
Das werden wir jetzt gleich sehen.
Chat, ich glaube, es wird echt Zeit, den...
Den 4M-Champ zu reviven, oder?
Der 4M-Champ war schon nice.
Ich glaube, wir reviven.
Chat, ich glaube, wir reviven den 4M-Champ.
Aber...
Aber mit anderem Ansatz.
aber mit anderem Ansatz, nämlich
mit
direkt
KVM QEMU
und nicht LibWirt, weil LibWirt
dazwischen sackt.
Nee, Python ganz bestimmt nicht.
Das Ding, der neue VM Champ,
den gibt es entweder
weiterhin in C Sharp, wozu ich tendiere,
oder
in Go.
Ich will einfach
Distributable Binaries haben
Und das geht ja mit Python
Ich habe jetzt ja
Zu genüge ausprobiert
Nicht gescheit zumindest
Ne, in Rust
Also, wenn ich damit nie fertig werden will
Und die Motivation verlieren will, dann mache ich den Rust
Und wenn ich
Super abgefuckt sein will, immer während ich es
Programmiere, dann müsste ich ein C++ machen
Ne, ne, ne, das machen wir
schön in C-Sharp oder Go.
Ich tendiere zu C-Sharp,
weil ich bin ein riesen Fan
von Spectre
Console. Beste.
Ja.
Über Kommandozeilen
UIS.
Sowas gibt's für Go leider nicht.
Ich lass mich gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Jetzt kommt mir nicht mehr dieser ganzen Bubble-Tea-Geschichte.
Das kannst du damit
überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
Hast du?
Nice.
Ness, die Sharp funktioniert wunderbar unter Linux.
Du kannst die Sharp
kompilieren mittlerweile. Du brauchst kein installiertes
.NET. Du kannst auch ein self-contained
Ding machen, was die Sharp... Aber du kannst mittlerweile die Sharp
komplett zu einem Binary kompilieren.
Und wenn du das
auf dem passenden System kompilierst,
ist das lauffähig
auf...
Seit
seit Ubuntu 16.04
oder so.
Wie lange läuft eigentlich
der Installer hier?
Der VM-Champ wäre schon dreimal fertig gewesen.
Okay.
Alma Linux is now successfully installed.
Glauben wir ihm das mal?
Gucken wir mal beim Booten zu.
Der sollte jetzt in Terminal booten.
Ich hoffe, die IP bleibt gleich.
Sonst muss ich gleich in meinen Rauder gucken,
was das Ding für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Okay, nice.
1, 1, 9.
Webkonsole?
Warum hat das Ding standardmäßig
eine Webkonsole?
Was bin ich denn da überhaupt drauf sehend?
Dann 1, 9, 2.
1, 1, 9, 90, 90.
Ah, HTTPS, gell?
Advanced.
Proceed.
Max.
Was da mittlerweile alles für ein Krempel mitkommt bei so einem Red Hat.
Ich kenne das nicht.
Ich kenne nur die Minimalinstallationen, die wir auf der Arbeit haben.
Und das, was wir auf der alten Arbeit haben.
Da war weder Standardmessung, Rap-Gui oder sonst was dabei.
Das sieht mir erstaunlich nach Cockpit aus, ja.
Cockpit.
Ja.
Aber ehrlich gesagt,
so dumm finde ich die Idee gar nicht mal.
Dass das standardmäßig dabei ist.
So blöd ist das gar nicht.
Ich wüsste ja nicht wirklich,
wozu ich es verwenden würde.
Okay, können wir uns da jetzt...
Moment, ist denn jetzt überhaupt SSH schon eingeschaltet da standardmäßig?
Würde ich jetzt mal erwarten bei einem Server.
Ja, okay, fix SSH, bam.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Das habe ich mir mal in so einer Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktion zusammengebaut,
dieses fix SSH-Kommando.
Das ist total fehleranfällig,
aber das verwende ich jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren oder so
und ist einfach beste.
Okay, der Server heißt Localhost, das ist optimaler Name.
Okay, also.
Ich sollte Root-Rechte haben.
Ja, ich hab Root-Rechte.
Also, yum update.
Wir müssen gleich mal checken, ob Bash-Completions und sowas installiert sind.
Install.
Apple Release.
Okay, Bash-Completion und so ist alles installiert.
Yes.
Noch zu so später Stunde wach?
Moment, in welcher Zeitzone bist du?
Also T-Mux, H-Top, D-Stat, Gitz, was brauchen wir noch, Netcat, H-Top, ah ne, hab ich ja schon.
Okay, yes.
Epel hab ich schon.
Yes.
Okay, dann lasst uns das Ganze doch jetzt mal ausprobieren
Wie funzt das?
Ich hab doch hier eben irgendwie so eine
So eine Anleitung gefunden
This is how it works on Fedora 40
Gnome Desktop Free RDP
Sudo-U Gnome Remote Desktop Win PR
What?
Was ist Grinzel?
Gnome?
Remote Desktop?
Control?
The fuck?
Da gibt es ein extra Command-Line-Tool für?
Okay, whatever.
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal,
wie der Dude hier das gemacht hat, okay?
Moment, das ist aber...
Das ist aber...
Okay, dann wollen wir uns als Max einloggen.
Das wäre mir tatsächlich lieber als Root.
Das ist okay so.
Dollar User.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Zu viele Buchstaben.
Das ist nicht Best Practice Passwort.
Oh.
Dann mache ich was?
Sudo minus U Gnome.
Win PR Make Cert.
Leute, ich werde das einfach mal ganz stumpf,
diesen Mist hier copy-pasten, okay?
Hat anscheinend funktioniert.
Enable.
Ja, wunderbar.
Juckt mich nicht.
Set Credentials.
Ähm.
Äh.
What?
Was?
Was soll denn das hier bedeuten?
Sind das, hab ich denn das die Zertifikate, die ich gerade generiert hab, oder was?
Ne.
Hä?
Okay, das ist Gnome Magic.
Oder, oder, oder also Root.
Okay, Gnome Magic.
Keine Ahnung.
Absolut kein Blastenschimmer.
Systemctl now enable.
Okay.
Excellent.
AddService.rdp.
Ja, das ist sinnvoll.
Ist das standardmäßig überhaupt an?
Wenn man das so installiert.
Das hängt mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen lang.
Soll das so sein?
Gucken wir mal.
Systemctl
Status
Gnome
Remote Desktop
Ähm
Geil
Okay, das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert
Warum?
Weil
Max, hast du das neue Video von Morpheus gesehen?
hat ein gutes ich gucke die videos von morpheus gerne wir sind die immer für
stream ein bisschen lang das problem ist sonja hat ein fass aufgemacht okay wir
sind die fünf team ein bisschen lang weil ihr kennt mich wenn ich 32 minuten
video gucke ich laber ja alle fünf sekunden rein da brauche ich eineinhalb
stunden
Okay, was genau hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Gnome, Remote, gibt es da irgendwas?
Failed with result, timeout.
Start operation, timed out.
Geil.
Und was macht er für eine Start operation?
Man kann sich das doch irgendwie listen lassen.
Ich gucke da immer.
System CTL, System D, System.
Gnome
oder Graphic.
Ja.
User
Lib Gnome Desktop System.
Das macht er.
Und das geht nicht? Warum geht das nicht?
Das ist einfach
denied. Das geht nicht.
Guck, das
Denkt sich einfach so, ne, hab ich kein Bock
Okay, dann würde ich sagen
Machen wir jetzt nochmal das mit der Firewall
Sollte jetzt eigentlich für lokal nicht wirklich
Was damit zu tun haben, aber wir machen es trotzdem mal
Und dann rebooten wir
Reboot fixt immer enorm viel Zeug
Man muss ja mal sagen, ein bisschen mehr
Ein bisschen mehr Error-Ausgabe
dürfte das schon haben,
dass man weiß, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Das macht gar nichts.
Sagt einfach Nope.
Timeout. Kein Bock.
Oder ist das jetzt gestartet?
Netstat?
Pulmen?
Ne, ist nicht gestartet.
Okay, brechen wir ab.
Machen wir mal dieses Fireball-Gedöns.
Und jetzt machen wir das hier nochmal.
Geil.
Okay, wir wissen nicht warum,
aber es startet auf jeden Fall nicht.
Okay, das haben wir gemacht.
Ach, guck mal, hier gibt es auch nochmal eine Readme zu, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist vielleicht besser, das ist das Offizielle.
Also.
ZDLS, CZ Credentials, NEP Enable.
To enable remote controlling, run.
What?
Okay.
RDP Server Certificate Invalid.
Okay, ich mach das hier grad nochmal.
What?
Ist das jetzt ein Problem, oder?
Okay.
generate tls key und zertifikat sie hier okay
okay ich mache das jetzt einfach noch mal was da steht nicht nicht dass ich
nicht verstehen würde was was da eigentlich gerade passiert
Okay.
Also das hat jetzt
gefunzt, oder was?
Okay, Firewall haben wir schon gemacht.
Und jetzt das da.
LDP-Server-Certificate
is invalid.
Geil.
Ja, Moment.
Ist das überhaupt hier
Local Share
Gnome Desktop
Das ist da überhaupt nicht.
Das ist debated.
Die Anleitung ist falsch, oder?
Es muss slash TLS
heißen.
Das muss Slash TLS heißen.
Hä?
So vielleicht?
Okay.
Ist das jetzt wenigstens da?
Nee.
Als welcher User läuft
der Krempel da oben? Ach so!
Das läuft als User genau im
Remote Desktop.
Sudo
Minus
Sudo minus U minus I
Minus bin Bash
Okay, gut
So, und jetzt
Firewall Gedöns haben wir gemacht
Okay, Z-Key
Okay, das hat funktioniert
Das hat auch funktioniert
Set Credentials
Oh
Ah hier, Username, okay
Max
Okay
LFP Headless Enable
Was?
Code Not Enabled System Service
Ich sehe schon, dass das
Funks wieder wahnsinnig gut.
Das ist ja super.
Also, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Man kann ja über X11 sagen,
was man will. Aber dann hat man
einen RDP-Server installiert und dann ging's.
Das ist ja wieder super
arcane Magic, was man hier
machen muss.
Du sollst Shell nach
ETC Shells pipen.
Was?
Was ist denn ETC Shells überhaupt
jetzt schon wieder?
Ach so, weil der...
Ah.
Okay.
Enable Headless Single Server.
Achso, ja, das geht ja so schon mal nicht.
Alter, was will es von mir?
Pay to connect to user scope
bus via local transport.
What?
Was habe ich denn da vorher gemacht,
was auch nicht funktioniert hat?
Hier.
Execk irgendwas.
Ja, das funzt ja nicht.
Vielleicht wegen Root-User?
Aber normalerweise musst du...
Ach, Minus-Minus-User
ist das.
Ah.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Und jetzt?
Ist es jetzt an?
Nee.
System CTL.
Status Gnome.
Okay, das ist nix.
Alter, ist das wieder durch die...
Das ist eine User Session Ding
Was war denn jetzt der Unterschied
Zwischen
Zwischen dem Blogpost und dem hier
Was hat denn der Dude am Ende nochmal gemacht
Das machen wir mal
Das machen wir mal weg
Das machen wir mal wieder weg
Dann machen wir jetzt hier
Disable
Minus now
Das machen wir wieder weg
So und jetzt
Enable control
Okay das sollen wir noch machen
Ne Moment das
Das ist wirklich Trick 17 wieder
Und das sollte man jetzt als...
Als Gnome-Dingspumps hier machen, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Und das soll man auch nicht als normaler User machen,
sondern als...
Gnome-Remote-Desktop-Service vielleicht?
Oder auch nicht?
Alter, das ist so...
So unverständlich, Monkeys!
Oder macht man das alles als normaler User?
Und nicht als Gnome Desktop User?
Okay, nochmal ausloggen.
VNC?
Wer redet hier von VNC?
Wer redet denn hier von
Ne, das geht so nicht
Also das ist wirklich nicht easy
Weil man keine Ahnung hat, was eigentlich passiert
Also das kann ich schon immer hier damit nicht machen
So, hier damit
Kann ich das aber
Auch nicht
Wie lässt man sich jetzt den Status davon anzeigen?
Kann man da sowas hier machen?
Oder muss man da so machen?
Und nie benutzt?
Is added as a dependency to a non-existent unit gnome session.
Ja, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nein, ich will ja nicht Gnome Session.
Ich will ja nicht Gnome Session ausführen.
Ja, das habe ich ja schon längst gemacht.
Ich will ja nicht, das will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich will ja, ich will ja das hier.
Ich will das systemweit aktivieren.
Wir müssen nochmal kurz googeln hier ein bisschen.
Handless
Ja, Google
Wir finden da bestimmt eine Antwort zu
Ja, dieses Gedöns haben wir schon gemacht
Ja, dass ich mich per RDP drauf einloggen kann
Das ist ja nichts zum Ausführen
How to enable ADP Remote Login
Okay
Also
Enable Headless
Ja ich will
Moment muss ich
Muss ich dafür Gnome Session installiert haben?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, eben nicht, eben nicht
Aha, hier gibt es einen Ansible-Stelz, für was macht der denn?
okay da macht das gleiche hier was wir auch gemacht haben so du grünen blut
ctl
ist im prinzip genau das was wir hier gesetzt haben
ja ich würde es hier noch mal aus was was dieses komische also
Also das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Ach, hier muss man minus minus System machen.
Okay, das hier machen die als Root dann.
Griddle, Griddle CTL.
Griddle.
Grydl CDL
So, das haben wir gemacht
Das mache ich jetzt nochmal
Set Credentials
Max, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Bam
Grydl
Ja, das hat ja nicht funktioniert
Gnome Remote Desktop Service Restart.
Okay, nice.
GG.
Ja, das funzt ja nicht.
Das timeoutet ja.
Und wir wissen nicht, warum.
Gibt es da vielleicht
Warlog?
Irgendwas?
Ich meine, Journal-CTL haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Aber so wirklich
ergiebig
war das jetzt nicht.
Sehr aussagekräftig, sehr aussagekräftig.
Fail to start.
Da weiß man gleich Bescheid, dass man nichts weiß.
Verify Setup.
Okay.
Es scheint, es scheint,
es scheint
prinzipiell zu stimmen,
was ich hier eingestellt habe.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Reboot.
Reboot hilft immer.
Guck mal was er hier macht beim Rebooten.
Immer
Rebooten.
Da sind wir wieder.
Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir wirklich wieder da sind.
Status.
Gnome.
Remote Desktop.
Dead.
Es ist dead, Leute.
Dead-ge.
Tja, so einfach ist das nicht, wie man sich das Ganze vielleicht vorstellen würde.
Was macht er denn vorher noch?
Macht er denn vorher noch irgendwas?
Ja, hab ich den Kram überhaupt installiert?
Der hätte doch bestimmt gemeckert, weil ich das nicht installiert hätte.
So.
Ja, install.
Das gibt's noch nicht mal.
Ach, das ist auch für Ubuntu.
Login CTL
Enable Linger
Graphical
Haha
Also ich sehe schon, das ist nicht so easy
Okay
Weil sich die Leute immer lustig drüber machen
dass der einzige Google verwendet.
Ich habe übrigens
einen Cloud
Anthropic Account mittlerweile.
Könnten wir jetzt fragen,
wenn ich das Passwort hätte.
Habe ich schon mal ein Passwort selbst auf einem anderen Account.
Ich habe mir aber kein Cloud Account
gemacht, sondern ich habe mir ein
einen Mammoth
AI Account gemacht.
Da kann man mit einer relativ günstigen
Subscription alle möglichen Models
verwenden.
Okay. Ich hab ein
nackiges, oh das darf man bestimmt nicht schreiben,
ein nackiges
Red Hat 10
als Server install.
Wie komme ich da nun
Remote per RDP drauf?
Bam. Auf ChatGPT.
Erzähl.
Nein, ChatGPT.
Das ist falsch.
Das ist dumme Scheiße, was du laberst.
Du bist dumm.
Ja, ja, mach, mach, mach.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Das ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Es ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Was wir tatsächlich machen können, ist, dass da, falls das ein gültiges Ding sein sollte, ist es tatsächlich.
Und dann setzen wir das Default Graphical.
Machen wir einfach mal, um zu gucken, ob es dann funktioniert.
Es installiert jetzt erstmal 3000 Pakete.
Das halbe Internet wird runtergeladen.
Warum ist das Quatsch?
Weil XRDP.
Das ist mittlerweile komplett Wayland-based.
Und das musst du mit Gnome RDP Session oder wie das heißt machen.
Wir gucken mal.
Aber es ist halt auch geil, dass du keinerlei Fehlermeldung kriegst, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Okay, wir probieren nochmal was aus.
Lip.
Ja.
Also das ist ja das, was nicht funktioniert.
Gibt es da sowas wie Verbose?
Äh.
Verbose.
Gibt es da überhaupt irgendwas?
Minus Minus Headless
Ähm
Moment, Moment, Moment
Ne, ne, System ist doch richtig
Okay, da gibt es halt einfach gar nichts
Geil
Oh, Moment, das ist CashUS
Let's set tulben
Läuft da irgendwas?
Chat, seht ihr da was? Ich seh da nix
Da müsste irgendwas auf 3389 laufen
Wir können ja mal checken
Da läuft nix
Ja, Kups läuft da drauf, weil wir jetzt ein komplettes Desktop-System installiert haben.
Also das funzt nicht.
Ich meine, da gibt es halt auch wieder null Fehlermeldung.
Das hängt einfach.
Okay, pass mal auf.
S-Trace.
Okay, nice.
Resource temporary unavailable.
Sehr gut.
Welche Resource dann?
Debus.
Root Cache Bus.
Und jetzt hängt es einfach und macht gar nichts.
Sehr nice.
Excellent.
Haben wir die China-Chinesen AI?
gibt auch sagen die chinesen worden not selected seit ist kaputt
Kommst du da draus, schaffst du das FD...
Ach, hier!
Aber das Ding könnte doch mal
irgendeine gescheite Fehlermeldung wenigstens raushauen, Mensch.
Okay, wir rebooten jetzt nochmal.
Wir rebooten nochmal und gucken.
Okay, die China-Chinesen-Seite ist kaputt.
Wir fragen, ob wir diese tolle Google-KI bekommen.
Ja.
Hochmodern.
Der ist so hochmodern, dass er nicht startet.
Moment.
Moment, ist das ein Ding?
Kann man das auf einem deutschen Red Hat wirklich so machen?
DNF Group installt Server mit grafischer Benutzeroberfläche.
Erzählt mir nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Also, dann keck-double-ue ich mich aber weg, wenn das funktioniert.
Ne, funktioniert nicht.
Das hätte mich jetzt aber auch gewundert.
Jaja, das haben wir ja alles gemacht.
Das haben wir...
Befehle zum Erstellen.
Siehe offizielle Dokumente.
Es gibt da sogar ein offizielles PDF von Redhead zu.
Guck mal hier.
Remote.
Okay.
Configure the Firewall
Das haben wir gemacht
Reload, okay
Open Settings
Ja, nee
Okay
Machen wir es halt mal so über das GUI
wenn das irgendwie besser funktioniert.
Letztlich ist es Teil der Gnome-Air.
Also, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Ich gehe in die
System Remote Desktop.
Ich will das halt headless machen, ne?
Äh, was zum...
Was passiert hier gerade?
linux remote desktop remote remote desktop ok desktop sharing ist aus
Allows desktop shares to control the screen. Yes auto connect
Beste perfekt
Okay, das passwort ist gut so das fragt mich auch bei gnome ab dass da kein ok knopf und sowas hast
Du kannst oben auch noch Remote Login machen
Oh tatsächlich
Ja hab ich ja
Hab ich
Das ist alles schon eingeschaltet
Aber es startet halt nicht
Jetzt läuft es.
Aber das ist echt dumm.
Max?
Yes?
Okay, jetzt haben wir hier unseren Gnome.
Ich muss aber echt noch gucken,
wie man das Headless hinbekommt.
Hallo?
Es ist ja geil, dass der Login funktioniert
prinzipiell, aber...
Okay.
Jetzt geht es einfach wieder zu.
Excellent.
excellent excellent oder auch nicht
das war auch gut ob das jetzt immer noch nach dem nach dem reboot da ist aber wo
war jetzt dieses red hat dokument wo sie sagen okay option ja konfigurieren
Remote-Login. Ja, haben wir doch gemacht.
Hätte es doch genau das gleiche
nochmal.
Ne, das ist Desktop-Sharing.
Das andere war Remote-Login.
Ja, angeblich ist das total easy.
Aber es funktioniert nicht.
Das werde ich morgen mal auf der Arbeit ausprobieren.
Stell ich mir so eine neue VM.
Jetzt läuft's!
X, Free, RDP.
Yes.
Domain?
Äh, ne, User.
Okay.
Guck mal.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen funktioniert das jetzt.
Und es funktioniert auch sehr lackfrei.
So, was ich jetzt gerne noch machen würde, ist...
Wie startet man?
Freiwillig, ich muss RDP machen
Ich muss RDP machen, Max
Es geht nicht anders
Wir bekommen neue
Wir bekommen neue, oder wir können uns neue
VMs beantragen auf der Arbeit
Mit einer Grafikkarte drinnen
Und
Nachdem auf
Ich muss Red Hat 10 verwenden
Red Hat 10, aber eine VM mit Grafikkarte
Das heißt, ich brauche Remote Access über Wayland und das geht nur über RDP.
So, also man kann hier doch irgendwie sagen, man möchte nur eine spezielle Anwendung ausführen, oder?
Das geht doch hier irgendwie drüber.
Weiß jemand, wie das funzt?
Was der Fehler war?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, unter
Advanced Start.
Das gibt's bei mir nicht.
Du hast Mist erzählt.
Nice.
Aber das geht irgendwie.
By the way.
Ich würde das hier gerne
fließen wieder.
Wie komme ich denn hier wieder raus?
Ach, das ist...
Ich kacke nur.
Connection Settings.
Display.
Local Resources.
Hier vielleicht?
Okay.
MSDSC Execute Single Application.
Das geht ja prinzipiell.
Configure ADP Settings File or use Remote App.
Open the saved
LEP file.
Single application.
Also dass das geht, hat man ja gesehen vorhin.
Urar.
Gibt es da auch irgendwas Neueres?
Shitrix!
Okay.
Wir machen das mal anders.
Ich will einfach nur prinzipiell wissen,
ob es funktioniert.
Launch only
specific application.
Standard Application alias
Das klappt doch nicht
Das ist doch halluzinierter Shit wieder, oder?
Ja, dachte ich mir
Oder?
Deckel?
Das ist halluziniert
Help?
Äh, what?
Jetzt.
App.
Was kann man machen?
Slash.
Äh.
Slash App.
Hoch.
Programm.
CMD.
Command.
Was kann man machen?
CMD.
Kackel.
Okay, das fand ich so schon mal nett.
Aber wir müssen erst mal gucken,
dass wir das, was wir mit Linux hinkriegen.
Kann man hier das Passwort
irgendwie mitgeben?
X-Free-RDP
Passwort.
Minus V Serverport.
P.
Slash P können wir machen.
Okay. Slash
P.
1, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Okay.
Anscheinend nicht.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine
beschissene Syntax, Mann.
So.
Und nun?
So, wenn wir uns hier drauf eingeloggt haben,
dann, dann exekuten wir es.
Wir exekuten X-Term.
Wenn irgendwas geht, dann X-Term, Leute.
Wenn hier irgendwas geht, dann X-Term.
Ist eigentlich mittlerweile...
Hat man denn, wenn...
Wenn wir Red Hat haben am Start, Red Hat 10, hat man denn dann auch noch XFCE oder irgendwie sowas dabei?
Ne, natürlich nicht.
Oh, ich hab nur diesen dummen, hässlichen Gnome Desktop.
Gibt's da nicht... Okay, gibt's KDE vielleicht?
Okay, KDE gibt's. Immerhin. Immerhin.
Ey, Cosmic gibt es nicht bei Red Hat.
Das ist zu advanced für Red Hat.
Which Xterm?
Okay, BinXterm wollen wir haben.
Kann man hier Copy-Paste?
Okay, immer.
Das geht schon mal.
Also, was brauchen wir hier?
Slash App.cmd.
Und jetzt sowas hier, oder?
Na.
Das war
Chibade, das hatten wir ja noch auf. Das ist ja Blödsinn.
Was ist das hier?
Oh, da kann man die Verbindung trennen
oben.
Mit was hast du da...
Das ist Standard KDE. Hier, guck mal, das ist...
Wie ging das nochmal?
Add or manage panels?
Oder auch nicht?
Ja, das ist das ganz normale
Standard...
Activity panel was es da gibt okay kdss ist wieder zu high iq für mich
Aber das ganz normal ist
Was?
Ich will keine normale Set...
Ich will nur das Xterm starten.
Haben das vielleicht Gnome Desktop RDP gar nicht?
Es ist Gnome Valiant RDP Server.
Ah, dann ist es klarer.
Alter, JetGPT labert doch nicht.
Classic.
Okay, ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich glaube, das geht so nicht.
nur über RDP eine einzelne Anwendung
zu starten.
Wobei, warum
fandst du das eigentlich nicht?
Weil der Installer,
der Installer ging doch auch.
Launch Single Application.
Ja.
Ja anscheinend... Wow!
Anscheinend ist das nicht so einfach, wie ich gedacht hätte.
Minus App.
Ja, an so erinnere ich mich auch noch dran,
dass man das früher so machen konnte.
Minus App.
Aber das geht ja anscheinend so nicht.
So, App.
Programm.
Und dann Path.
jetzt so juckt es nicht das ist bestimmt nicht supported könnte ich mir vorstellen
immerhin ist es ein halbwegs brauchbarer desktop naja
Ich mein
Es sagt schon ziemlich
Guck mal, es stimmt noch nicht mal hier unten
Diese
Es
Es stimmt ja gar nichts
Geht das denn wenigstens, wenn ich das mit Windows mache?
Ja, ist mir doch egal, ob das insecure ist.
Kann man das wenigstens resizen irgendwie?
Ne.
Okay, wenn ich es Fullscreen mache, geht das.
Aber kann ich das Display-Setting, kann ich es irgendwie resizen vielleicht?
Ne.
Resolution ist auch komplett nicht änderbar.
Das ist so...
Ey, da kommst du dir...
Das hat 1995 besser funktioniert.
Außerdem ist das eine eklige...
ekliger Gnome-Krempel.
Aber das Terminal laggt weniger.
Haben wir dann hier West-Term
bei Red Hat dabei?
ONC wird wahrscheinlich genauso wenig funktionieren.
Oder nicht besser funktionieren.
Kein Westterm.
Wie gibt man dann bei MSTSC die Auflösung an?
Display? Hier.
Aber dann kann ich nicht richtig resizen und so.
Das ist auch dumm.
Aber immerhin, immerhin geht das.
Immerhin.
Die Windows-Taste wird natürlich von Windows
gecrapped, das ist klar.
Ey, das ist
wie 1995.
1995.
Was ich mache, ich versuche mich
per RDP auf Lelux-Kiste
einzuloggen. Es muss eine Red Hat
10 Kiste sein.
Ich mach das nicht aus Spaß. Nicht, weil ich das geil finde.
Sag ich gleich.
Aber ich mein, immerhin könnte ich hier ein Terminal
im Fullscreen haben und mich freuen.
Hier, Firefox.
Ich muss das morgen mal
auf der Arbeit ausprobieren.
Restroom, Download.
Linux
Letup
Ist das
Ist das mittlerweile auch
Übrigens
Das ist Gnome ist komplett unbenutzbar
Gnome hat keine Taskleiste
Wo ich zurück aufs Terminal kann
Ne
Und die anderen Sachen sind komplett
Von Windows gehyjagt
Wie ist das eigentlich
Wenn man jetzt
Wenn man dieses Windows Remote gedönst
Wenn man das jetzt
Fullscreen startet
Hört es dann auf
Meine Maus und Tastatur zu crappen
Am Host
Ah ja, okay, das funzt
Leider kann man nicht richtig resizen
Aber okay, immerhin.
Das funktioniert zumindest schon mal halbwegs.
Yam install
flathub. Geht das?
Näh.
Yam what provides flathub.
Gibt's das bei Red Hat überhaupt?
Näh.
Ja, es gibt für...
Ich kann mir auch einfach das Binary runterladen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ja, CentOS 9.
Easy.
Leute, wir installieren uns einfach
random Shit aus dem Internet.
Beste.
Westerm.
Okay, das Funst.
Und das ist auch null laggy.
Das ist auch nicht laggy.
Hab ich mich verschrieben?
Bei Flatpack?
Ah.
Du hast recht.
Ah ja.
Ja, remove Western.
Flatpack.
Dann installen wir das mal.
Ja, install Flatpack.
Ist sogar drauf.
Flatpack install.
Ah, no remote refs found
Ich muss diesen graben
Kannst du Flatpacks auf der Arbeit verwenden?
Nö
Ah, das ist wurscht
Das muss ich jetzt nicht machen
Binzeli nochmal random
Stellt aus dem Internet
Ah, zumindest ist Westterm nicht am Ruckel
Oh, jetzt ist es irgendwie broken
Aber als normaler User geht's
Also ich mein immerhin ist Westterm
Jetzt sehr zackig
Ich mein ich kann
Mit dem Gnome Desktop leben
Theoretisch
Was wir jetzt nochmal probieren können ist
Wart mal
KDE Wayland
RDP Access
Geht das?
Okay, wir installieren jetzt...
Okay.
10, install, KD.
Ich kann nicht Sunshine nutzen.
Ist das nicht dabei?
Das ist doch bestimmt Bullshit,
was das Ding wieder anzeigt.
dummes KI gedöhnt.
Ja.
Wenn ich hier nach
YAM search
Plasma suche, finde ich den ganzen Krempel
doch.
Oder nicht.
So viele neue Paketsysteme.
Ja, Snap kannst du schon mal
komplett knicken. Snap ist der größte
überhaupt. Flatpak ist ganz nice
und AppImage ist
vom Ansatz her auch ganz nice, machen
aber manchmal die Anwendung Probleme.
Und auf manchen Systemen geht
AppImage auch nicht.
Da wo kein
Fuse installiert ist.
Ja gut, Cargo, Pip,
Nougat
und das ganze Zeug, das sind ja
NPM, das sind ja Package Manager für irgendwelche
Dependencies, die eigentlich für Programmier
Sprachen, Libraries und so gedacht sind.
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt echt ein bisschen planlos.
Was muss ich denn installieren, dass ich...
KDE.
Ja, install. KDE.
KDE Desktop, oder?
Oder Plasma?
Plasma Desktop.
Das muss ich installieren.
Yes.
Excellent.
Grup install.
Ich glaube, man wüsste welche.
DNF Gruplist.
Ah, da können wir tatsächlich gleich mal checken.
Auf.
Fail to launch Terminal?
Wie? TF?
Warum willst du auch bei Root hin?
Bist du dumm?
Blame das an Terminal.
DNF.
Group List.
Alter.
KDE.
Moment. Einfach KDE.
Alter.
Group.
Group. Install.
KDE.
Ja sagt es doch einer, einfach KDE installieren.
So die Preisfrage ist jetzt nur, wie kann man das auswählen?
Kann man das beim Login dann irgendwie auswählen oder wie ist das?
Was macht Groob?
Es installiert mehrere Packages, die zu einer Group gehören.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das hier mal dicht.
Gehen auf unsere 4M.
Und jetzt die Kreisfrage.
Früher, ne? Als es noch sowas wie X gab.
Ich sage nicht, dass bei X alles geil war.
Auf jeden Fall ist es das auch nicht, ne?
Das ist jetzt ja nur Knorr-Gedöns.
Wie startet man neu hier so?
Wie startet man?
Wie switcht man da jetzt um?
Oh.
Alle Advanced, oh shit.
Ademir mittlerweile Wayland? Keine Ahnung.
Also...
So geht das schon mal, net?
Ähm...
Switch Gnome to Kare.
da gibt sogar ein eintrag das ist diese dumme red hat enterprise database
ok fedora gibt es stimmt auch
Aha
Okay
Da steht doch was sinnvolles
Äh, ups
Das machen wir jetzt nochmal
Ich installiere alles, Leute
Juckt mich nicht, gib ihm
Volle Pulle
Change your
Disable GDM
Enable SDDM
Gibt's nicht
Ähm
Äh
KDM
Plasma Display Manager
Äh
Plasma Login Manager
Gibt's nicht.
Aha.
Hä?
Ach so, Plasma-Login.
Geil, Alter.
Minus, minus, now.
Okay, startet der jetzt auch
dann hier?
da ist es funzt und haben einen kd oder sieht schon sehr nach kde aus das ist
gleich viel neuer als dieser knack knaum so und jetzt wie war das jetzt remote
desktop sharing vnc remote desktop
sehr remote login to connect using apps so porting der system users auto start
und login meinetwegen logan ist system password
war es das eine enable rdp server
Gibt's net?
Da läuft bestimmt noch
Der
Das andere Ding
Net set
Tulben
Ja, guck hier da
Pekel
Gnome
Einfach alles mal weg
Wo genau im Namen drin vorkommt
Siehst du, schon funktioniert's
Schon funktioniert's
Haben wir hier
3389, irgendwas laufen jetzt?
Haben wir, easy
Okay
Connect. Yes.
Äh.
Ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Okay, der braucht einfach nur.
Oder auch nicht.
Was ist das für ein Kack-Noob?
Also...
Ich sag mal...
Das könnte besser funktionieren.
Muss man da noch irgendwas einstellen?
Nö, oder?
Reboot, oder?
Chat, Reboot, Reboot
Reboot
Und dann schauen wir mal
Ob der Kram nach dem Reboot auch automatisch angeht
Also ich würde halt KDE
Um ein vielfaches lieber haben
Als Gnome
Gnome ist so ein Schrott
Nee, ich hab das doch disabled
Oder hab ich's nur gestoppt?
Okay, nix gibt's
Das heißt, man muss sich einloggen
dass es überhaupt was passiert.
Okay, das ist natürlich
schon nicht so geil.
Das ist schon nicht so geil.
Also KDE,
RDP ist nicht so
funktionell,
wie man das gerne hätte.
Oder
fragt er mich jetzt auf der anderen Seite,
ob ich mich einloggen darf irgendwie.
Hä?
What?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was liegt das an dem unteren Haken?
Was meinst du?
Also das funzt nicht.
Das hier, das tut nicht.
KDE RDP Black Screen.
In den...
Du meinst, meinst du hier?
Remote.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
was sind das jetzt schon wieder das ist vnc jetzt das ist jetzt vnc ich will ja
nicht ich will nicht vnc ich will rdp haben
remote
Meinst du hier oder was?
Ne.
Ah, das ist aber doof.
Kein ADP Clip, Bautchen.
Ja, ja, doch, doch.
Ok jetzt hab ich nicht mehr tippt beim Passwort.
Ok es funktioniert also das klappt nicht.
Was?
Was bin ich hier?
Moment.
Was?
Was soll man machen?
What?
Wo du hier gelandet bist
Nicht lange, weil ich muss gleich weg
Wir machen ganz eklige Sachen
Und versuchen hier
Für uns
Per LEP auf
Red Hat 10 zu verbinden
Aus irgendwelchen
Gründen geht das nicht
Warum nicht?
Ist das rude?
Ach so
Oh.
MKDier minus P.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt würde ich sagen, Reboot.
Zack.
Aber wir haben ja schon mal weit gekommen.
Also ich weiß jetzt zumindest, ich kann ein KDE installieren, da funzt kein RDP.
Ich kann ein Gnome installieren, da funzt RDP, wenn auch nur sehr um die Ecke.
Ja, was mache ich denn da jetzt?
Warum nicht VNC?
Weil ich keine Kontrolle über das habe, was auf dem Client installiert werden darf.
Es geht nur RDP.
Chat, ich glaube, wir haben es ein bisschen zerstört gerade.
Plasma Shell hat keinen Bock.
Es gibt nur zwei.
Es gibt nur zwei Desktop Environments.
Unter Red Hat.
Die hatten mal XFCE, aber XFCE ist halt noch auf X.
und X wollen ihn nicht mehr supporten.
Naja, es hat ja auch was sehr von Windows-artiges.
Okay, also einloggen.
Das muss man ja machen, sonst geht's nicht.
So, und jetzt schauen wir mal.
Das Funds jetzt?
Äh.
Okay, daran liegt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber anscheinend
unter Gnome funzt es.
What?
Ich soll anderes
FFM-Pack installieren?
Seid ihr nicht mal ganz bei Trost, oder was?
Was ist Inksi?
Also das scheint ein größeres Problem zu sein, dass KDE Remote Desktop not worked.
Das finde ich halt ein bisschen kacke, wenn das, ich kann mich doch da für tägliche Arbeit nicht drauf verlassen, dass das RDP teilweise nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das muss einfach funzen.
Und deswegen sage ich halt auch, ja ich verstehe ja, dass das alles geil ist mit Wayland und viele neue Sachen ermöglicht.
Aber wenn du halt irgendeinen Kram willst
Der einfach seit 15 Jahren
Funktioniert
Dann ist halt so ein X-Tor aber noch nicht verkehrt
Also anscheinend
Anscheinend findest du es nicht
Aber XRDP geht nicht unter Wayland.
Die haben, ich glaube nicht, dass, die haben, die haben ja gar keinen.
Oder haben die noch?
Weil dann wäre ja easy.
Aber ich glaube, die haben nicht mehr.
Für die Zukunftssicherheit ist auch blöd.
Die haben, glaube ich, keinen.
Ne, ne, haben die nicht mehr.
Logg dich aus.
Wenn ich mich auslogge lokal aus dem KDE,
dann geht das gar nicht mehr.
Das hat witzigerweise bei...
Moment.
Wo ist überhaupt der Ausloggenknopf?
Chat?
Wo ist der Ausloggenknopf?
Ich sehe den nicht.
Shutdown?
Ah!
Ey!
Okay.
Naja, aber jetzt ist es wahrscheinlich weg.
Vermutlich.
Naja, guck jetzt.
Jetzt läuft da gar kein...
Jetzt läuft da halt gar nichts mehr.
Naja.
Okay, Chat. Trotzdem nice.
Muss ich auch morgen auf der Arbeit ausprobieren.
Gucken, ob das was bringt.
Ich werde jetzt die Kiste hier erstmal ausschalten.
Ach, hab ich gerade gemacht. Okay.
Die Kiste erstmal ausschalten.
Schnell was essen. Und dann muss ich weg.
Und wir sehen uns
spätestens am Wochenende wieder.
Aber es könnte durchaus sein, dass ich morgen Abend
schon wieder am Start bin.
Falls ich irgendwelche Probleme beim Einrichten hatte
Machen wir vielleicht hier, basteln wir vielleicht sogar morgen Abend weiter
Schön, dass ihr alle am Start wart
Wenn euch solche Streams gefallen
Ein bisschen Linux-Bastelkram, ein bisschen Microcontroller-Bastelkram
Ein bisschen Programmier-Bastelkram
Ein bisschen CTF
Kaputtes Server fixen
Und sonst was
Dann könnt ihr mir ein Follow da lassen
Ich freue mich immer, wenn die grünen Pfeile in meinen Analytics nach oben zeigen
Und ich sehe auch hier ein paar neue Leute im Chat
Also würde mich freuen, wenn ihr jetzt den Follow-Button klickt
dann sehen wir uns nächsten stream wieder wir sehen uns leute bis dann macht's gut